el perímetro del jardín de erwin mide 60
metros si lo largo del jardín mide 2
veces lo ancho del jardín cuáles son las
dimensiones del jardín ok entonces erwin
tiene un jardín vamos a dibujarlo por
acá esto es lo ancho del jardín y no
sabemos cuánto mide por lo cual vamos a
decir que mide w metros lo que sí
sabemos es que lo largo del jardín mide
2 veces lo ancho del jardín pero lo
ancho del jardín estamos diciendo
ahorita que vale w por lo cual aquí
tenemos que poner wv aunque esto es otra
vez lo ancho del jardín entonces mide w
y esto es lo largo del jardín así es que
mide dos veces lo ancho del jardín o sea
dos por w entonces lo que sabemos
nosotros es que el perímetro del jardín
de ervin mide 60 metros y como sacamos
el perímetro pues sumamos la longitud de
todos los lados
figura entonces el perímetro mide este
lado mide w así es que aquí tenemos que
sumar una w después 2 w 2 w
más la longitud de este otro lado que
mide w más la longitud del último lado
que mide 2 w ok eso es igual a tenemos 1
+ 2 o sea 3 w 4 w y 6 w el perímetro
mide 6 w
ok seis veces lo ancho del jardín sin
embargo también conocemos la cantidad
exacta de metros que mide el perímetro
si aquí tenemos que el perímetro del
jardín mide 60 metros o sea que este
perímetro que sacamos aquí es igual a 60
metros y entonces nos acabamos de
encontrar con una ecuación con una
variable donde nuestra variable es
cuánto mide lo ancho del jardín y por lo
tanto podemos encontrar cuánto tiene que
valer esta variable
que el perímetro sea 60 como dice el
ejercicio que sucede que y entonces nos
queremos deshacer de este 6 por lo que
vamos a dividir entre 6 de los dos lados
del igual y de esa forma se cancela este
6 con este 6 y aquí dividimos 60 entre 6
es igual a 10 y obtenemos que w es igual
a 10 y listo
entonces w es igual a 10 2 por w es
igual a 2 por 10 o sea 20 w si verdad 10
2 por w es igual a 20 y ya tenemos las
dimensiones del jardín es un jardín de
10 metros por 20 metros